we could be at any high-end lounge in
Manhattan but we're not we're the
brand-new Jenny of the financial
district and to cater to the area's
high-end clientele saving for free
design elements such as leather booths
copper ceilings wood paneling and the
centerpiece of it all the bar and it's
not just any bar it's a high-end
specialty craft cocktail bar let's have
a drink this is the bourbon bacon
cheeseburger sauteed mushrooms and
onions and it's Gator bon delicious with
a bourbon sauce so we're gonna pair this
one with our bourbon cream soda
it is a bourbon maple syrup cocktail
it's bourbon a lot of vanilla notes
anyway so we kind of highlight those
with a little fidelity in the cream soda
but alcoholic yeah Soto with it's like
adult cream soda
those are zesty nachos tortilla chips
little fresh salsa a pico de gallo sour
cream and a little taco seasoned beef
we're gonna be pairing that with our
pepino today if you know one of my
favorite cars on the list
it's a mezcal cocktail so like tequila a
little smoky err little earthier because
of the way it's made we make this
cocktail with some quick cucumber sea
salt and lime tastes like summer
meat potatoes and a Manhattan does feel
like Don Draper this is your last meal
of the day to go immediately to sleep
after you eat this while you're drinking
them it's all about indulgence with this
salmon has a strong flavor for fish it
can definitely stand up to a red wine
not you know not a big Cabernet not a
Malbec Walter Gary but a nice light
really drinkable Pinot Noir
perfect Denny's is most famous for is
the Grand Slam bacon salsa eggs and
pancakes
it's classic Americana breakfast Grand
Central - and a bottle of 2004 vintage
Tampere yum for $300 champagne breakfast
it sounds crazy expensive davit $300
breakfast at Denny's but that bottle
itself goes for about $400 anywhere else
sometimes so you're getting a great deal
cuz it's Dennis you know where we're
value brands and it pairs well if
campaign is a perfect breakfast rate